I have to man I mean I am single but I'm
I'm not ready for mingling yet Nikki
Bella was having a hard time moving on
from John Cena after calling off her
engagement last season I feel such a
huge piece is just missing for me but
now the tables have turned in a sneak
peak of total Bella's fourth season
having kissed another guy
yes that's Nikki nearly locking lips
with one-time Bachelorette frontrunner
Peter Krause and on a date with her
former Dancing with the Stars partner
Artem well we spend a lot of time
together and they need a lot from us and
so I'm someone who when that happens I
kind of shut down but Artem knows how to
break through me and he's really like
learned how to like let my guard down
and so I used like my Russian therapist
it's great Russian tariffed is that like
[Music]
the chemistry was clear back in the
ballroom Artem and Nikki even discussed
helping with her wedding choreography to
marry John an amazing person would you
understand
are you gonna do like a big ballroom
dance no that yeah right so she goes nah
I feel like my guests are gonna expect
it so I'm gonna let him down if I don't
yeah but I mean I'm doing black-tie and
so I think I have to do some type of
walks
I know a guy yeah who's that yes my
co-star in studio it looks like Nikki's
dating life will shake things up and
season four but not without some
conflicting feelings in the world
vodka Rousey is undefeated in person
Polydor you ever knocked down with
authority on schedule
it's confusing because I'm still in love
with them the couple opened up to et
during their ups and downs before ending
their engagement for the second time
relationships are tough they're hard and
it's hard work and a lot of times it has
to do with like looking at yourself to
being like okay there's a problem am i
causing it I kind of am I'm being way
too selfish here we need to talk about
this that leads to a lot of tough
conversations and sometimes people don't
want to have those conversations John
and I we absolutely love each other and
we care about each other a lot we are
best friends and right now we're both
giving each other time separately and
maybe there's hope that we reunite in
the future I love her I don't want to
live without her
[Music]